you should play level 1 so we can all
have to stop this okay
Oh like a level one okay prepare to get
destroyed computer just won one game on
level one it's going down
d3 well so quick okay
let's just destroy it crush its hopes
and dreams we have to develop and then
destroy it's actually playing rezone no
nevermind it's not playing reasonably
let's win a queen oh that's all the
attack where's my means Wow okay let's
take stuff well we better not flag me
though it's because it's playing quickly
okay chin flag me oh I dropped a piece
okay I could have taken the free Brooke
wait this is bad I don't want to lose
this on fish level one play at six this
move this is becoming competitive why is
it so competitive
okay there we go
I just have to win material I'll not
lose material you know I forced me how
did starfish level one fork me wow this
is so bad no no stop oh my gosh I
thought I should just retire I just lost
the stock just level one what oh it's so
bad to doesn't deserve to be have any
sense of victory thanks for letting the
new sub but okay wait no this is not
happening
it's not happening wait okay let's flake
no let's play Bishop d2 Huntress on why
is it so good this is just psychology
roses rip I don't know what that means
place he formed it's so fast to like
level one might be like as strong as the
other level thanks for the pity blitz
why do I have double pawns everywhere
sorry I missed a free pawn I keep
missing things also oh jeez it's okay
don't laugh at me okay no I'm off of
Bishop it's going down that's something
I don't fly my username is oh thanks for
reminding me yet again what's not flat
it's not treating with me no it's not
gonna dot me so I'm about to fire though
yes let's go let's go
okay my God my my sweet sweet victory I
was about to get dirty flags yet again
my mouse feet so slow but yeah no mercy
I don't want to put that on YouTube
that's too embarrassing man that's so
strong I was not expect I thought it was
just like get mated with him like 10
moves it plays randomly also yeah thanks
for the bits